what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are finally here with Gods by Jonathan
Hickman where he over the course of the
next eight months is going to be
rewriting the entirety of the Marvel
Cosmic Landscape the cosmic entities
Gods the whole nine yards and what this
does is this picks up at what's
basically a party of sorts right kind of
a get-together with all these people
wearing different masks and somebody's
wearing a mask that makes them look like
Spider-Man and there's these hosts right
they kind of Welcome everybody to this
place right welcome users of The Craft
you have passed your first trial the
secret Words which begat the hidden path
and so now it's just kind of like enjoy
yourselves right be carnal enjoy your
you know physical Delights basically go
find a room and bang if you want to but
that's when we're met by the arrival of
a guy named win now win is a wholly New
Creation in Marvel Comics and in the
events leading up to gods and the
teasers behind what was going on with it
a lot of people thought it it was the
return of Clyde wincham which would have
been dope Clyde wincham is the Marquee
of death dudes ridiculously op but the
thing about this is Win is like a holy
new guy we will learn about him but when
he shows up here along with the guy
that's with him they're not wearing any
masks and so it's kind of like how in
the world did you get in here because
the only people who can access this
place are people who are wearing masks
however do not fret we have masks that
you can purchase for a price although
it's not really worth discussing what
the price is for those of you guys who
are familiar with Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers no it's not
the Centers Market but it would be dope
if it was I love the Centers Market and
Avengers The New Avengers one of the
coolest Concepts in the history of
Marvel Comics but something dope will
show up here and so what ends up
happening is we get this kind of
explanation right the blonde guy his
name is Dimitri and as he explains he
says I am a proxy in service to the
Natural order of things and the chained
Apprentice of the one and only Avatar of
the powers that be now that's one of the
things to understand here and it's kind
of a new creation by Hickman the natural
order of things and the powers that be
they're basically two rivaling factions
but the idea here is they still serve
the traditional Cosmic entities that we
know
eternity Infinity The Living Tribunal
that kind of thing exactly how far
reaching they go and what their
interaction with those Cosmic entities
are we don't fully know and we'll find
out I'm sure over the course of this
although there will be a pretty dope
reference now there's so much cool stuff
that happens in this comic so what ends
up happening is they figure out pretty
fast this whole thing is a ruse right
and there's kind of like a little
computerized device they have that
basically grants them information that
they wouldn't normally be able to access
on their own that kind of thing and what
we're basically told by way of this
device is that these are two beings who
are effectively masquerading it's a
great big huge ruse here they're the
baron and baroness of Wolverhampton lord
of the land and Lady of the Lake and it
says these are titles they hold in
absistentia as they abandoned their seat
of power years ago they're currently
visiting these Fair lands indefinitely
and according to their visas with
surgical dispensation in essence her
name is nimu De lock which I think is
how you pronounce that and he's the lion
of wolves once they're forced to remove
their masks we end up finding out what
the nature of this whole ruse is which
is that in effect they basically lure
people here they are people that do have
some measure of magical abilities but
they lure people to these Grand parties
putting on this error that is a place
where those who practice Witchcraft and
magic and so on and so forth can hang
out but none of them are legitimate
they're probably just general
practitioners of magic right like card
tricks people who work in Las Vegas
right just simple magic tricks guys like
David Blaine but what they do is when
they bring them here they end up picking
basically somebody or a few people and
they consume them they literally eat
them right now more or less they eat
their bodies but they also can assume
their souls and so the result of this is
that they're not supposed to be here
right and so in essence like the
question this asked is really like why
is Win here in the first place why would
a guy of his level of power be brought
to a place where some folks are
hoodwinking people and then consuming
their flesh and their souls and he's
told it's because there's a demon here
that's not supposed to be here and in
fact it's actually residing in the
bathroom and so once he gets there he
basically faces off against this thing
now it is not like the most significant
moment ever but it does go towards
establishing him more so than that we're
told that this demon is chaotic in
nature in effect it seems to stem from
like the flickering Realms the land of
c'thon powered by chaos magic we're not
explicitly told that but the fact that
it's chaotic in nature really seems to
lend itself towards that the other part
of this is that because of the
mannerisms and the way in which wind
talks a lot of you guys who are DC fans
and particularly vertigo fans will pick
up on the fact this guy is very similar
to John Constantine which is not the
worst thing ultimately they defeat this
demon and that's basically it and then
they end up traveling to a bar where
wind goes in and Dimitri's made to wait
outside this is where we get this really
huge kind of like Drop in information on
what's going on it's not the huge
explosive part things haven't popped off
yet but it is cool for information and
the reason why is because what we end up
finding out here is this guy win is Sir
redwin lord of the Highlands root of the
world tree salt of the earth that he as
far as This Woman's records show is the
Avatar of the powers that be now the
reason why this matters is because this
woman's name is Aiko a-i-k-o and her and
win are lovers the problem with this is
that it's very much a kind of Romeo and
Juliet story not insofar as like all the
romance and they end each other's lives
and so on and so forth are in their own
lives or what have you but in the sense
that they are paired with the opposing
factions he is a representative of the
powers that be but she works for the
natural order of things she didn't fully
understand what she was getting into
when she was brought into quote unquote
the organization so that seems to
indicate that the natural Order of
Things stretches everywhere from just
normal corporations on Earth out to the
cosmic entities and so on and so forth
again it's very Cloak and Dagger and
very mysterious but in essence she's
been offered a position that is
incredibly high ranking within the top
100 right like the last Prime of the
Centum which is kind of like their Inner
Circle if we had to go that route right
like the most capable or the highest
ranking 100 people the reality is it's
an opportunity she can't turn down more
so than that the factions of the natural
order of things and the powers that be
are at war with one another and she
basically says like if I decide to take
this role I will officially join their
ranks and in doing so I will be immortal
now for when himself he more or less is
Immortal he's lived for a thousand years
and so the idea that he has here and
kind of a very Cavalier nonchalant way
is to Simply say well I mean we can just
lie right we can stay married and we can
just lie because she's essentially his
wife they've been together for about
five years or so right he's like we can
just not tell anybody that we're staying
together and we can make it look like
we're going our separate ways but she
makes a really good point in saying the
level of power that we're dealing with
with these gods that we serve right
these incredibly powerful beings they
will find out and when they do they will
destroy us and as much as I love you I'm
not willing to die and even when himself
says but like I am but ultimately she's
made up her mind right and she's like we
need to get a divorce we need to go our
own separate ways once she realizes that
when refuses to do this that his stance
is like you could send the papers over
but I'm never gonna sign him she does
the only other thing she can do which is
kind of make a sort of physical
declaration by shooting him in the head
now it's not going to kill him right I
mean it's not enough to actually kill
him it's really more her just kind of
demonstrating to those individuals who
may or may not be watching her really to
the gods of the natural order of things
she's officially ending things with him
right that was 10 years ago when all
this happened with when that was 10
years ago now we jump to the present
moment and basically he travels to the
sanctum Santorum to visit Dr Strange now
when he gets there he's actually met by
Wong instead of Stephen Strange and when
he asks where it is that he's at the
response of Wong is Stephen Strange is
at the library of Worlds where everybody
else is and even when says I hate this
place so one of the things that we're
basically learning about the character
of win is that while he is a new
introduction to us this guy's been
around the magical landscape for eons
and he's traveled seemingly everywhere
that anybody can travel within the
universe itself as far as his
experiences go he seems to be on par
with Doctor Strange not so much in terms
of power but in terms of his knowledge
and everything that he's seen which for
being a thousand years old kind of makes
sense now as for the library of Worlds I
love the library of Worlds it was one of
the coolest things that Jonathan Higman
introduced in Avengers and New Avengers
the idea behind the library of Worlds is
that it's a place that exists in the
Nexus of all creation going into the
library of Worlds you can access any
Universe from this place and for those
of you guys who are unfamiliar with
Marvel Comics there's a lot of places
you can do that right the impron
crystals somebody like Doctor Strange
you can just jump into different
alternate realities or different
dimensions or what have you but the
whole reason why he's called so many
people here is because there's what's
called a Babylon event taking place now
the Babylon event we don't know anything
about this is again another New Creation
by Jonathan Hickman we don't know
exactly what it means but we will find
out what I also want you guys to take
note of is that there is a veritable
who's who of the Marvel universe that's
here for example you see people from
Advanced idea mechanics but you also see
Dr Doom the Scarlet Witch Reed Richards
of the Fantastic Four it's a coming
together of the most capable scientific
and magical Minds within the Marvel
Universe and what Stephen Strange says
here is that when he's asked by CLIA is
there truly a Babylon event taking place
of course CLIA being the one-time
apprentice and even wife of Stephen
Strange and now she's just kind of a
chick who's out there he says last night
there was a bleed on the plains of
Mercator which is just an ultra
Dimension that exists out there and he
says when I arrived I found the guardian
twins blinded and the infernal glyph
over which they stood Sentinel stolen I
had to delve deep but these were the
last images burned into their minds it
appears to be the Proto Mage cubisk core
long thought Dead who disappeared years
ago and what he says is that he seems to
have returned more or less at the Apex
of his strength but one thing is sure
her he now has the staff of the Living
Tribunal but when people start asking
the question especially with Amadeus Cho
are we sure it's a Babylon event I don't
really see it one of the things to know
is that Amadeus Cho is one of the
smartest people in the Marvel Universe
in fact he's the eighth smartest person
alive and while Amadeus Cho has never
been a person that seems to have been in
any equal capacity involved with Doctor
Strange what Jonathan Hickman is doing
here is he's kind of introducing this
Babylon event as something that anybody
who is well versed in science and Magic
knows about it's a dreaded event right
it represents the end times and so again
it's new to us as the reader they've
known about it for quite some time and
so what we do is we're kind of
introduced by way of Doctor Strange to a
guy named Saint mare Circle right the
second centavar of the symptom basically
he is among the top 100 right down from
number one we don't know who would be in
the number one spot if it would be
Reserve for like the god of the natural
order of things or what have you but
this guy basically tells them what
Stephen Strange told you is accurate but
it's also a lot more dire than that what
he says is somewhere along the line
right this guy comics core had basically
accessed an advanced idea mechanics
facility and that's when we switch over
to actually Comics core himself and like
this explanation that he gives and he
says when my God made the universe he
placed each of us inside a box of course
exclusively talking to this member of
advanced idea mechanics and he says many
cannot see this box the idea of it the
very shape of it but the box is your
home and oh how you hate it right and he
says you love the dream and hate the box
but what I tell you now is the truth and
it is the hardest truth you will ever
hear I am here to destroy the dream and
wake you from your Slumber and so one of
the things that he draws reference to he
says you sign scientists and your
curiosity you drilled a hole in
existence to mine for exotic matter and
never ask the question where do my
actions lead what do my actions feed now
here's the thing there's two potentials
on what this guy's talking about the
first is an event that transpired that
we simply just haven't seen the second
and the one that I'd be willing to bet
my money on is when they made a Cosmic
Cube because Advanced idea mechanics did
create a Cosmic Cube and as anybody who
read Jonathan Hickman's Avengers The New
Avengers knows Cosmic cubes are the
result of somebody drilling a hole or
really creating a kind of portal in
space and time and accessing the realm
of the beyonders and so a Cosmic Cube is
quite literally the power of a beyonder
confined in a Cube's shape it's the
reason why a Cosmic Cube is equally
powerful to The Infinity Gauntlet it is
the ability to wield the energy and the
power of beings that are not omnipotent
that were more than capable of
annihilating every Cosmic entity in
existence we don't definitively know if
that's the case but it would make sense
that Jonathan Hickman has done that and
that What's Happening Here is The
Logical end result of the first time
they did it now again we don't
definitively know right we're just kind
of left to guess in terms of what's
Happening Here but that's when everybody
basically realizes in the midst of all
this this guy begins to cast a spell and
that's when you switch over to guys like
Jericho drum Stephen Strange where they
ask is this truly a spell that he's
casting is he truly causing a Babylon
event and the response of Stephen
Strange is it's most likely true yes the
real power of the staff of the Living
Tribunal is that the user and the staff
can write a spell and rewrite reality in
a Continuum leaving no room for a
counter spell so in effect whatever
spell he creates with the staff cannot
be undone that's the true ability of it
and that this would be a Babylon of that
right the end times the ending of
everything now I'm sure Hickman will go
into more detail in terms of what a
Babylon event means on a greater scale
and how far reaching it can be but in
the here and now everybody here agrees
they all need to act they all have to
respond in some capacity and so in what
seems like kind of a out of left field
moment when and Dimitri end up back
outside and then they pick up a penny
and the responsive win is like it's a
John Wilkes Booth Penny I bet we could
trade this for something really good and
so what we do is we transition to The
Collector and literally win shows up
here with a John Wilkes Booth Penny and
presents it to the collector and The
Collector is totally enamored over it
but only for a particular reason he says
it's from Another Earth lost in the
great collapse the now extinct forgotten
by all but a select few
brain71241 you see it should have been a
dark mirror but somehow was not perhaps
it can be again if I'm surmising here
assuming Hickman's not referencing some
unseen event he's referencing the
collapse of the Multiverse from Avengers
and New Avengers right like the ending
of everything because that's one of the
things to remember right if you read
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers The New
Avengers then you read Secret Wars 2015
then you read all the different Comics
that came in the aftermath of it with
the exception of black panther who used
the time Stone when everything was being
Rewritten at the very end of Secret Wars
he used the time Stone to jump back to
the past before all of it happened with
the exception of him and maybe like a
couple other people that one guy from
the Jessica Jones story who murdered his
wife almost no one remembers that secret
wars happened almost nobody remembers
the collapse of the Multiverse very few
people do the collector seems to be one
of them and so in this moment what you
also have is Dimitri who picks up on a
clock with six hands who also you know
basically wants to trade for the clock
and then when who wants to trade for a
book that has an eye on it it's not the
dark hole before you guys get super
excited it's not the dark hole I thought
it was but it is actually going to be
incredibly important to this story and
so at that point we switch over to
What's called the contemplator's garden
now the contemplator is a very old
character in Marvel Comics and in fact
he's also one of the Elders of the
universe but the contemplator very much
fancies himself a kind of Buddhist right
almost like a Buddha type character
where he focuses more on Inner Harmony
right yin and yang that kind of thing
and I know I'm mixing like you know
religious and philosophical viewpoints
here but like you get the point right
kind of finding basically balance within
oneself and so being presented a clock
with six hands he says three hands for
perceived time and three hands for the
axes of all things the synchronicity of
power life and purpose all waxing and
waning as if there was some Grand Design
to it all and so as thank you for the
gift he presents when with four vials
and while he is very wordy here and
saying that each one contains a precious
gift right all variables are to be
determined all possibilities are in your
hands right grab one and remove all
doubt what he's basically saying here is
that it's not something like a game show
where it's like door number one door
number two door number three right let
me show you what's behind door number
three and it totally changes the
probabilities of whether or not the
person will guess between doors one or
two what this is designed to do is say
each one of these vials possesses
something of astronomical value and
worth but they're all equal in their
value and worth so you can't choose
wrong right that's essentially what he's
saying here and that in response to that
when ends up grabbing one of the vials
and then in turn brings it to the
possessor and that in bringing it to the
possessor he breaks the Vault and inside
of it is a key and that this key serves
the purpose of accessing a Security
Vault right and so by presenting this
key to the possessor the possessor then
comes back with a box and what he does
is is that in opening the box it's
essentially a translocator to get from
point A to point B and that where this
all seems kind of really crazy in Cloak
and Dagger by using this translocator it
allows him to basically be transported
to the Grand Bazaar of the trader and
the Grand Bazaar of the trader is
exactly what you think it is a guy who's
willing to trade things for other things
and this particular instance you end up
having win who meets with Stephen
Strange now Steven strange was actually
part of an event that was going on what
kind of jumped back to that here in a
second because honestly the comic jumps
back and forth and so it's kind of
easier to cover this before we get to
everything else that what ended up
happening is Stephen Strange had
essentially bailed out that everything
else was just kind of a distraction and
that him quote unquote rallying the
troops when he was in the library of
Worlds was a way to basically get them
to focus on the immediate problem while
he can focus on a more Grand and solid
solution but what's Happening Here is
Stephen Strange is actually bargaining
for use of l-drak now for those of you
guys who don't know what l-drak is
l-drak was at one point a human being at
least we believe he was a human being
but when he underwent the terrigen Miss
and then his inhuman genes also known as
the useless genes in Marvel Comics were
essentially activated he turned into a
giant portal and so as a rare case in
Marvel Comics he's an inhuman that
actually serves a useful purpose but the
way that eldrak works as a portal it's
really really cool he's not one of these
guys where you just walk through a
portal and just kind of go wherever you
want to go right he's not like The Siege
perilous where you walk through and you
start over again or anything along those
lines the way that eldrak works is that
when you pass through the portal he
sends you to where you need to go and
sends you there at the precise moment
that you're needed right so it's really
really cool in terms of how his
teleportation system works but what ends
up happening is Steven strange basically
barters with the traitor representing
him with some Trinkets and whatnot in
order to use eldra track right at the
moment when Wynn and Dimitri arrive and
what wind does is he presents the
traitor with basically a translocator of
Cree design that would allow him to get
to anywhere that he wants to be and
where the traitor just kind of initially
dismisses it the response of win is
actually I just came from the
possessor's Vault so you could use this
thing and you could teleport yourself to
the possessor's Vault and who knows what
kind of trinkets you could find in that
place right and ultimately the bargain
is made and so what ends up happening is
when doctor strange and Dimitri pass
through the ldrock portal to arrive
precisely when they need to now at this
point we jump back to the immediate
aftermath when you had Stephen Strange
calling all the forces together and
saying we have to find a way to stop
this Babylon event and so what you get
is Black Panther Reed Richards Amadeus
Cho in his Hulk form Jericho drum also
known as like brother Voodoo these guys
all respawn but they're fighting this
battle on multiple fronts more so than
that what this Babylon event basically
seems to be is the unleashing of
Eldritch creatures right Eldritch demons
onto the Earthly plane one of which
looks like Cthulhu right so it quite
literally is bringing about the end
times and that's why they all kind of
begin to panic in that moment because
these are beings of astronomical power
and so the way this whole plan is
orchestrated those individuals from
Earth right Reed Richards t'challa
Doctor Doom Amadeus Cho they will
basically focus on the Prometheus pit
that's feeding the Eldritch gods and
shut the pit down those individuals who
are capable of Magic on Earth so people
like Wong and so on and so forth right
that they would focus on defending the
rift against those Babylon creatures
that are coming out those Eldritch
monsters and that the symptom right the
natural Order of Things those forces
will deal with the cubics core right
this guy who's just incredibly powerful
the problem with this is they're all
painfully outmatched woefully outmash in
such a way to where there's seemingly no
conceivable way for them to win even
when you have Reed Richards talking to
t'challa and these are the two or at
least two of the smartest people in the
entirety of the Marvel Universe they can
really like shut this down in about an
hour but they don't have an hour in an
hour they'll all be dead right they'll
all be annihilated and destroyed and
like that's gonna be it and so even when
those members of the natural order of
things make their move against like
Cubist core he takes them all out in one
Fell Swoop because what he says is my
master assumed that your master would be
the most offended and that he would send
you here now this kind of seems to be
alluding to the idea of it just being a
power play right like if anybody's gonna
take over the Earth and wipe out
everything on the planet It's Gonna be
Me Right like that kind of a thing
because the way that Hickman builds up
the nature of the natural order of
things and the powers that be while they
are astronomically powerful they also
seem very human and basic in nature and
so he had basically given cubis core
this kind of device that would allow him
to take out the entirety of the forces
of the natural Order of Things who were
at Bay and pretty much all of them but
Ico are eradicated right they're all
basically destroyed and so in that
moment that's when when doctor strange
and Dimitri show up here at a moment
when it feels like everything is lost
and while when is an avatar for the
powers that be right off the bat we're
kind of shown he's not all powerful it's
not like he rolls in here snaps his
fingers and the day's saved it's not
that level of power which I think is
cool to make him a guy that's like
comparable to Stephen Strange but not
like the fulcrum or the one above all or
the Lemmy tribunal or something along
those lines and so what he ends up doing
is he had basically told Dimitri at a
previous point in time that the book
that he possessed was a book of
astronomical power and it could not fall
into the wrong hands and so when he's
attacked by the Eldritch creatures the
book goes flying out of his grasp right
and then immediately like Cubist core
picks it up because Dimitri panics and
says win God's the book right you've
dropped the book and makes a huge fuss
out of it in turn Cuba's core comes to
the realization this book must be
something of significance the guy goes
to crack it open he starts reading it
and then everything ends everything just
stops right just boom done and that's
over with and this guy's defeated right
now here's the way in which it happens
and this is actually one of the coolest
things it's one of the coolest things
the way that it's done right you have
this conversation between doctor strange
and when where Steven strange talks
about how he's just too old for this
kind of thing right he's tired of
dealing with this kind of stuff over and
over and over again which really seems
to put off this idea that while even
though Reed Richards and t'challa and
Amadeus chill and those guys aren't
normally involved with this kind of
conflict this kind of stuff happens all
the time which if you ever read Jason
Aaron's run on Doctor Strange you
probably already know that right I mean
it's just it's it's mind-boggling the
kind of stuff that goes on in the
background but what when revealed here
is that the book was never an ultra
powerful book it was never
astronomically powerful and even like
Stephen Strange says like that was very
clever using the boots Hub book right
because the nature of this book as this
explained is that the longer you read it
the more it eats your mind and once you
start you simply can't break free and so
in effect when that guy cracked the book
open it started consuming all the
knowledge in his head and basically
there was no way for him to keep the
portal open he didn't know how to
continue Conjuring magic to make sure
that he could stay on top that was
essentially it now of course you end up
having the book that's basically taken
right and that's effectively it right
wind just kind of walks away with it but
it is kind of a cool moment because
there's this bit of a discussion right
where they kind of go back and forth for
a moment and it's one of those things
where Stephen Strange says like you know
I fight for the light and for causes
better than I and for fate based in
forever and her sister hope and life and
so on and so forth that is who I am when
he says things like that he's speaking
literally right like the cosmic entities
abstract beings that exist out there he
fights on their side and while wind
calls him out in a very John Constantine
kind of way like yeah that's really cool
it's a nice speech and everything you
know but here's the question right like
are you a good guy or are you a bad guy
and the response to Stephen is I'm good
and then he asks when are you good or
are you evil and the response of when is
who can tell the difference anymore like
I've seen it all right like I've seen
everything that's out there right and he
even looks at this idea of like the
powers that be and the natural order of
things as just these beings that don't
really care about right and wrong good
or evil anymore they just want to keep
Waging War against one another this is
basically alluding to the idea that
there is a desire to destroy these
Cosmic beings that are out there these
beings of astronomical power that seems
to be the goal of when whether or not
that will actually happen I don't fully
enough but I am excited to see how it
plays out because basically you know
Aiko runs up on him and she kisses him
says thanks for saving us you know and
then that's basically it but I'm excited
to see where this goes man with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end let me know what you think
down in the comments section about this
comic and I will catch you all later
peace